captain she's highly-trained deception
infiltration extraction she's Special
Forces I didn't versio inferno squad
commander versio you must be important
look at me so let's talk facts that's
what I'm here for
you have the activation code I've got
the ability to help you out just give me
the code
you know we can really use someone like
you just help me it'll help you it's
that easy
I'm gonna get what I want eventually my
best technicians are slicing into your
droid right now take out my offer I want
us to code the Empire's time has come
you don't have to go down with it you're
right
the Empire's time has come
[Music]
BZ 6 to 6
[Music]
right on time
let's go
[Music]
agent asked do you read me loud and
clear command overseer you're right on
time
I'm moving to the communications center
[Applause]
purge complete there's nothing for the
rebels to learn
[Music]
age tap time understood commander
prepare for extraction
[Music]
[Music]
a giraffe commander on deck Paddy's
zero casualties looks like you're still
second in command
oh I'm patient I can't wait
agent Miko those jump calculations were
perfect thank you ma'am
the landing wasn't too rough been
through worse remember the job s
incursion still wants my dreams contact
the Admiral
yes commander and the message the fleet
location is still safe today the
rebellion died
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Fiat give you a firing squad now
come on to versio report we have eyes on
a rebel recovery team Admiral but were
too late to capture the seven tours
what's the status of the dead stop
shield generator worse than expected
there's no way to repair or reactivate
the battle station is vulnerable
eliminate the rebels have returned to
the Corvis the Emperor's plan must not
fail yes sir agent hath with me agent
Miko cover us from here
[Music]
that's all we grew up and prepare to
move out
okay let's copy over them those rebel
come out it's must've already moved on
we should do we're near platform for is
there a shuttle there no TIE fighters
only even better
we should move carefully we don't know
how many rebels are out here and I will
deal with them the same as the rest
today we wipe out that scum once and for
all
look alive agents we can grieve later
right now we need to move
we need to reach platform for and secure
those Tie Fighters that's our only way
back to the carpet
agent Miko he's got a head yes come on
agent half contact me the traitor
I need to speak with the Admiral yes
come on down patching you through now
Admiral
infernal squaddies without me waiting at
door what's the situation
yes sir we'll contact you when we reach
the moss
I don't understand how this happened in
front was perfect something crucial
again the rebels were outnumbered and
outgunned it's simple the Emperor
underestimated the strength of our enemy
and we paid the price
Brandon I know we're alone I didn't put
that down from the trees up to the sky
hack it's not treason if it's the truth
don't fight RC RC you operate
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the Admiral created Inferno so something
like this wouldn't happen again I know
hard to believe this is all instead
[Music]
rebellion tried to make my friends we
already make them angry
someone told me once that rebellions are
built on hate I never stopped believing
it how are we supposed to fight that the
Empire will change just like it did when
they destroyed the first Death Star we
adapt or die
engines are operational commander
perfect timing
David Miko's get to the Corbin I'm right
behind you
order your ships retreat and join me on
here mr. return sir classified orders
come on person yes that infernal spot
the Admiral and I will run deeper with
you later
understood commander
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you wish to see me sir approach the
empress' dead
so what happens now we returned
commander the Empire will assault the
very foundation of the rebels pathetic
belief in themselves tell me I mean what
is the source of their belief help
correct this messengers presence is a
great honor one I choose to share with
my daughter
[Music]
aDNA versa operation cinder is begin at
once
resistance rebellion defiance these are
concepts that cannot be allowed to
persist you have had one of many tools
by which these ideas shall be earned
well he might messenger you to your time
operation centers the last command of
our Emperor and the first step in
securing our future Inferno is crucial
to its success what's our target you are
dog verified that information can wait
for now here our next assignments they
are unusual but these are unusual times
Oh commander do what you do best
[Music]
in preparation for operations cinder
we've been ordered to the Fond or
shipyards agent asked you and I will
retrieve experimental satellites for the
Star Destroyer dauntless and oversee
security from all faiths agent Miko you
have the corpus
[Music]
[Music]
come on we're secure the satellites good
mark Asian ma freighters inform the
Admiral that operations him to proceed
as planned
[Music]
[Music]
what's the plan commander keep this
started for your sake the rebels can't
learn about all green
[Music]
your clearance cap
thanks for the assist commander time to
take out those rebel ion cannon
you're clear come on the get sue the
haggis I'm sorting the enemy ship in
half
Jordan the inside when they give the
orders in the pill bed cover the
Dauntless
yes commander
[Music]
oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
navigating to Attack Position
[Music]
today your father will be proud
[Music]
the satellite for operation sender have
been delivered to Admiral Murcia our
next mission is equally important
Inferno has clearance to access one of
the Emperor's classified observatories
buried on the planet pilio it contains
dangerous artifacts our enemies could
use against the galaxy the observatory
is protected by a mantle defense system
agent Miko
we need your technical expertise to
disable it take what you need for an
expedition locate and destroy the
observatory
[Music]
[Music]
if the Empire's here what I sensed was
true there must be something special
about this place
you stay here our two scanners probably
spotted us William I heard you call out
it sounded like you needed help yeah I
do do you think you can get me out of
this
hold still I know who you are
why'd you help me because you asked
[Music]
[Music]
I've heard a hundred stories about the
Jedi they terrified me as a boy on
Carson but you
come on
need to work together if we're gonna get
out of here
whatever's inside these doors those bugs
don't like it there's nothing on this
thing how am I supposed to open was a
key why would the emperor have a vault
that can only be opened using the force
why do you think you're telling me the
man who destroyed the Jedi Order was
secretly one of them
no I'm telling you that as a boy on
Coruscant you were frightened of the
wrong thing
[Music]
there's nothing dangerous in here the
Emperor is protecting junk this is all
worthless not all of it
what is that I'd like to keep this
compass if you don't mind my mission is
to destroy this place why would I let
you do that because I asked thank you
I won't stop you from destroying this
vault wouldn't you say the Empire sent
enough damage to this world
[Music]
I'm glad we were brought together down
so what happens now we both walk off in
separate directions to pretend like this
never happened I don't think you can
there's still conflict in you
of course there's conflict in me I'm not
blind
I know what the Empire is capable of but
what else is there a choice
the rebellion no a choice to be better
may the force be with you
[Music]
you
welcome back agent mica the Admiral
needs us to extract an imperial Ally on
my home world of bardos the target is
Protectorate gleb a local official who
once mentored both agent asked and
myself I don't know how this connects to
operation cinder but I have to trust the
Admiral make the jump to bardos
that's the Dauntless the ship we rescued
on fondle why is it here first
delivering cargo was carrying a
satellite
moth Wraith said they were needed for
operation cinder
but he wouldn't tell us the target
either with the Admiral now I know I
satellites are aligned sir excellent I
did not call for you command diverse
here bardos is our target one of them
yes why the entire planet and its people
there they're loyal to the Empire the
Emperor commands it will purge this
planet and others fear shall spread and
the galaxy will remember who is in
control this is our home
Jabba is our home and we will do with
the Emperor commands I don't take orders
from dead men you take orders from me
activate the satellites now
[Music]
leaf Furtado's immediately recover
Protectorate led she is your only target
that is all
that is all
[Music]
contact agent in her stomach all of us
to the money to speak to him immediately
[Music]
we'll find Protectorate gleb in the
archive follow me
do you still remember your way come on I
don't forget so easily
agent anything like the locals must be
terrified it's just the beginning when
people see what we've done here that
terror will spread throughout the galaxy
I'm just surprised being on TV
our first these are our people this is
an imperial world a place we're supposed
to protect as well been evacuated their
fearlessness in the face of the storm
service discipline the Glen deserves an
early evacuation nothing Gleb oversees
the future Imperial leaders school here
she crafts soil capable troopers like
I'd like
now she's calling it a favor the people
are part of the oil to the empire why do
they let me suffer this is all for the
greater good commander none of this
looks good to me
Bardot's was our home back the Empire is
our home
operations cinder is a test to prove
that we are worthy awarded will be
coming you sound like my father is his
own daughter's life
target acquired get a move on glad she
is giving me orders now precious
commander we have a ship on landing Bay
- you'll be safe there go go now
go what are you doing stop this is not
our mission stand down
it's okay we'll get you off for all to
go no no nope our orders are clear we
ought to recover the protector of Gleb
alone things have changed look around
you man do you even recognize the Empire
no please don't do this
empires job is to save civilians from
things like operation cinder this is a
new empire if this is the new empire I
want no part of it I'm taking the orders
of my commanding officer
are they sure of it are these your
orders because if they are this is
treason
our oldest
[Music]
yes
then I have my over your weapon
[Music]
otherwise you will not ever see Anna and
I took Nicole abandon the mission
they've committed treason
it's understood return Gleb to me that
is your mission
I will take care of the traitors
[Music]
[Music]
I'd move us agent asked reporting
mission accomplished sir
congratulations commander has
[Music]
so we're not completely alone some of
our crew stayed with us protected the
refugees against those who wouldn't how
are they
shaken confused but safe just want to
know what's next we have to warn people
who the rebels they're just gonna toss
this in sunspot prison before we can
even say a word that's why I think you
should just take the Corvis and go leave
me a TIE fighter I'll set off a distress
call wait for the rebels to find me you
really think I'm gonna let you just
float out here alone tell we're Inferno
squad
you and me this is ideas of the Imperial
Raider quarters sending a general
distress call to the Rebel Alliance we
surrender
contacted general now so you thought it
was a trap
but brought them on board any we're
always telling me to take risks seemed
like the most irresponsible thing I
could do boy hello I'm general Lando
Calrissian you must be the Imperial
defectors I've heard so much about
general we've already told your people
everything we know let's take a walk
okay what is this a bad idea to settle a
bet Tripp thinks you're a be real spies
what do you think I think you're scared
running for your lives
listen you gave us good Intel our
operations Sinden in return I've got to
stop by this just
wait you're letting a sleeve that's
right start a new life find somewhere
safe somewhere you can track us we're
too busy for that
[Music]
we just got word that operation cinders
headed in that mood you have to stop it
I think we can handle it you're wrong
the Empire's changing concerns tactics
if that's the case why not come with us
help save that move
we're not here to join your rebellion
you can leave right now are you gonna
help us stop us you really trust us to
fight this idea
what can I say I'm a big believer in
second chances come on I'll show you
these chips
we don't even know how to put fly next
week's it should be easy for special
forces will see all Tennessee ride
so what's it going to be
all fighters begin your attack plant oh
good timing couldn't be better this is
Princess Leia or Donna my position
respiration you're clear to attack
everyone else pull back
[Music]
we're not looking at the same burning
stars right an imperial protocol is to
jump away to a safe location those ships
are headed straight for feed they're
gonna attack the city
[Music]
[Music]
danger leader four of us will have to do
and he would know your way around
machines I do go with me feed has a
defense system something that you use to
stop the Empire but the storm is damaged
power relays across the city until there
repair we can't activate anything split
up repair the relays when you're done
regroup at the palace got it yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I think we just won
oh I love you Hannes good work out there
but I'd expect nothing less from Inferno
squad so you've spoken to general
Calrissian you've done a lot of damage
to this alliance yes we have men and
there's no excuse for it watching you
fight today it's clear you're not just
running from the Empire this means
something to you it does we've been
fighting our whole lives it's taken us
too long to realize that we were
fighting for the wrong side this war is
far from over
we would like to help you if you'll let
us
people like you the reason hope can
prevail
hope is the reason we're going to win
welcome to the New Republic thank you
[Music]
senator Organa it's been a while
building a republic is busy work so it's
chasing after an imperial fleet it's
about to get busy on commander I need a
favor one of our generals has gone
missing I tracked him to Taco Donna but
he isn't answering his comm I need you
to find han Solo
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey Mazz for me another part Kellan
sling not until you paid for the last
one come on you know what's good for us
I don't know that you're good for
anything
where's my wookie chewies working on the
Falcon long-range communicator took a
hit back on Xiomara you never bring him
around anymore
you make him nervous you two are up to
something
spit it out you know our business goes
through me
I'm meaning an imperial turncoat says he
can help us free the Wookiees back on
Kashyyyk you seen him I swear if you
bring the Empire to my doorstep you know
I always cover my tracks come on now
help me out help Chewie
I don't know your men but it is Nate and
you may find that this crowd is
talkative
thanks Moz I owe you one
you owe me more than that han Solo and
don't you forget it
han Solo I'm imperial specialist Razia
spelled Dora it is a pleasure to finally
meet you
Shh you want to keep it down oh right
right because we're meeting incognito
come on we need to get you out of here
off we go then most definitions are
killed by apprentice statisticians
friends the earth I assume this is your
fault usually is what's my number one
rule solo no fighting
come on we got him
hey maybe today's not too bad after all
[Music]
why am I glad to see you
what brings you out here commander
General Senator or gone assess us I take
it back Chewie this is the worst day
imaginable
[Applause]
[Music]
right now
[Music]
one more time turn to Tucker nice shot
general solo I'm tracking another
rebound on your position I'll take him
out
just be sure you do come back don't
worry you can't get rid of us that
easily she's all yours commander telling
you go whatever you digit is relayed
it's not right I just fixed it you can't
blame me if it likes you now
Inferno squad shrim I haven't seen you
since Lando volunteered you for this how
you been
wonderful senator what's on your mind
commander
according to pel doors Intel my father
has been running operations on Bespin
and Sullust I'd like your permission to
find him and capture him you don't
report to me Ida
a fleet command might not approve us
undertaking such a personal mission oh
well we can't have an imperial Admiral
out there reinforcing the fleet ken I'd
appreciate you bringing him in commander
yes ma'am and may the force be with you
[Music]
the searchlights will enter the city
tasks will be in the overseers town
chilling station and stick to the clouds
so they don't spot us
Oh
[Music]
security has touched that we thought
getting to house won't be easy I have an
idea
we're not gonna like it
[Music]
okay we'll meet you at the tower until
then you stay out of sight
that new paint job will give you away
I'm just standing there soldier
move on get ready dill knowing Castile
put up a fight I'm looking forward to it
well brings back memories the earth near
towers straight ahead happens you'd be
on the top floor
where is everyone
[Music]
that star disjoint that must be has so
much for that plan
[Music]
get off the platform that's all of them
now let's find that ship
[Music]
well I said we needed a ship I should
have been more specific
it has weapons were for dear world for
it not to be a club car stealing
platforms dead ahead and three Star
Destroyers which we're going to blow up
you know what you were right the cloud
car was not a good choice for this all
we need to do is take off the fuel cells
and the explosion will cause a chain
reaction exactly all the way back to
those stardestroyers that is the
craziest thing I've ever heard
we have until on an abandoned Imperial
factory on Sullust
Admiral versio plans to recover a
weapons cache from inside
we are gonna steal it first I've called
in some help to guarantee we do triv
you'll be on the ground with general
Calrissian secure those weapons and call
us for escort no matter what they can't
fall into my father's hands
you have a bad feeling about this
I'd be worried if you didn't admiral
versus people are supposed to be here
now
we should call iDEN for extraction relax
one strike team will be fine and if it's
not
[Music]
Caravelle lasers this place is pretty
well defended for it
I only brought you for the gummy but
look at that tactical analysis give me a
break I know my way around Sullust after
all I did help liberate place that would
explain why the Empire is still here
okay
that was a good
problems solved
did you find us a ride
look I'm taking another enormous risk
shrimp I could kiss you move over so I
can drive
what can I do
[Applause]
pleasure
what's our cargo one desperate girls in
a ridiculous man in a cave
[Music]
[Music]
if I die here
I'm glad you will - thank you I told you
it would be fine
destroying that factory had a bigger
impact than we thought
Admiral Ackbar is calling all Republic
ships to jakku the whole Imperial fleet
is there - the equipment they would have
received from Sullust
I expect my father will be there - but
catching him is no longer our priority
this battle could be the end of the war
let's get in and we do what we can to
help
[Music]
[Music]
karabast I'm picking up distress calls
too many to count
Delf the Corvus is yours cover the sky
sure and I will help on the ground hold
on a minute
iDEN make sure you come back make sure I
have a ship to come back to
they sure if I hope you survive this
incredibly dangerous mission as well
Thank You Dale your friendship means
everything to me
[Music]
[Music]
distress beacons near your location
we'll check them out
detonators
I'd say we did good job down there
captain Lindsay this minute taking
carbon-rich right now and they've done
it with that for me how's it going up
there
hard to tell I think you're right I can
feel it it's almost over
today the Empire dies better late than
never
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to safety I'm finishing what we started
I'm gonna get my dad I didn't he's not
worth it I have to try down no go right
retreat
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
close one
[Music]
find it I'm okay tell I'm gonna find a
way inside you and trip follow the next
distress signal
we need to get my father off this ship
before it goes down
vampires time has come you don't have to
go down with it
this is a rescue attempt I politely
decline we have to come down
spec's me to leave too this is where I
belong I gave my life to this Empire for
to keep his strong heart beliefs all
that's left
you saw the Empire's weakness and
refused to let it consume you it makes
you stronger that's why you're leaving
here without me to sit in a zone I don't
but you do I mean you deserve to live in
peace go survive live
[Music]
gotta get to tell gotta stay alive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
idem it's over
we want
[Music]
the Droid tells me you're alive looks
that way
I'm glad now come on you gotta see this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
show me to the prisoners
[Music]
you know if you want it too high on my
ship
you could have just asked the map to
Skywalker you know how I can find it I
don't know what you're talking about
[Music]
I won't tell you anything
we'll protect you keep you safe safe
only were more Center took the map Paora
he took it sube hora
I have what I came for is yours now
clean this up
[Music]
you spare me the pleasantries ask we
both know that other sins
yeah and you don't get to be brave
because you are not a soldier anymore
don't catch it you're a coward
yeah you traded in your weapon for what
or in Gaga Undercovers you know I you
may have betrayed me but you tell you
let me down you will change don't we
Hey look at you it used to be Ted
ah well Ivan could do just about
anything except kill me
apparently
as
gideon please don't go after her
it won't end well for you
please
[Music]
[Music]
on the country-club I sought you out
because because you would useful to me
once we rebuilt your home and we allow
janata security to maintain control of
the system but in return you're falling
behind schedule you've allowed an
outsider to discover our plan well I
should leave behind a few of my men to
see that you do make sure you bury Dell
maker and his crew but leave the Cobras
alone I'm planning on it
[Music]
you